what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren as you can see I'm I'm in a leg I
just saw Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
and no spoilers in this review this is a
spoiler free review we'll do a spoiler
review later on but there are some
things I want to talk about and looks
like we were right Marvel's back after
this for those who have been feeling
that Marvel has been mid
that's what the kids call it nowadays
um it's not mid by any means at all a
lot of people were saying it's the best
Guardians of the Galaxy film I
personally can't say that but I think
everybody else is going to because there
was one aspect of this movie that is a
very personal tick of mine
it's it's very personal it's not like a
universal thing where I think a lot of
people are going to feel this way it's
very subjective just to my own personal
opinion and I will tell you what that is
uh when we get into that I will tell you
the specific part that I didn't like
that that bugged me
and this part is going to keep me from
saying that it's my favorite Guardians
movie just because of this one aspect
but big thank you to Marvel big thank
you to Disney for having me out there uh
there was a party after and I got to
hang out with the cast uh I hung out
with Karen Gillen spoke to her she's
amazing so kind Palm clementev she is
she's been one of my favorites for a
really long time mantis is one of my
favorite Guardians she's so funny I love
her and um I fist bumped Chris Pratt um
he was very busy uh saw Vin Diesel and
uh everyone was just so nice I spoke
with James Gunn I I thanked him for the
Guardians and I I thanked him for what
he's about to do for DC
um and and I spoke to Iman villani who
said she watches the channel and she
knew who I was which was amazing because
she as Miss Marvel is perfect man if
you're watching you are perfect perfect
casting can't wait to see uh the Marvels
but the movie itself
I want to say congrats to the cast
because their character arcs and the
ending of this film is perfect
it really is so I was worried about that
obviously going in because this is like
the end of the Guardians as we know it
right and we're talking about deaths and
like all the stuff like wondering going
into this movie like who's dying you
know
um it is emotional it's very emotional I
shed some tears a few different times I
was sitting next to you know my my very
good friends some of my best friends uh
Wendy from the movie couple with her
husband Dustin uh John and Greg from uh
the real rejects we're all shed in tears
we were I could hear them so I think it
was John I'm gonna call you out because
you're a man for crying because I was
crying too I heard some sniffling there
um they they do pull on your
Heartstrings
in a like rocket story and this is kind
of tragic for me because I have I named
my cat rocket after Rocket Raccoon and I
love her to death she's awesome many of
you have seen her you know on the
channel live streams so like we're going
through all this tragic stuff with
rocket I'm like my cat but um that's not
the aspect I was talking about
but but the character arcs the writing I
praise James Gunn for this they're
fantastic I think they
I'll just speak generally here to not do
spoilers I think they close in a very
good way and
speaking about the ending I think it was
perfect it wasn't what I thought it was
going to be but it was perfect it was
better way better than what I thought it
was going to be and having said that I
we've done a lot of Theory videos and
Guardians I you know I did one on what I
thought the post-credit was going to be
wasn't what I thought it was gonna be
gonna be I'll just say that uh we'll
talk about that in a bit but but
I was right about some things but I was
wrong about some things nothing that's
going to make you go well that's you
know stupider in the movie of course
nothing like that
um everyone I talked to loved the movie
and are saying like it's their favorite
Guardians film and with the character
arcs how they came to a conclusion
and and like left us off there and how
the ending was so perfect for me that I
felt I truly did love the film I did and
this is the best thing to come from
Marvel in a very long time like I
haven't been so excited
I think
um and I love Marvel you guys know me I
love Marvel
you know but
I I cried for happy and sad reasons and
I'll just leave that at that
and the part that I didn't like is what
I want to talk about so I I'm trying to
I try to think about the best way to
describe this Greg was trying to help me
um it's just how I feel I am very
uncomfortable with anything that is part
like Android Cyborg and part like human
flesh something that's living and like
that's the base of this movie how the
high evolutionary experimented on rocket
and all of these other animals and
creatures and made them half you know
living thing half freaking robot and
stuff like that and some of it I can
handle like rocket right or you know
nebula that's different but when it's
something else where it's like you know
you have like the upper body of a pig
but the rest of him is like a spider
that freaks me out and I hate it and it
makes me feel uncomfortable I hate
anything horror-esque scary movies I
don't watch them I don't because I just
get weirded out creeped out this feeling
that I get I hate so when I say that
it's hard for me to say this is my
favorite Guardians film that's why
because you know the the high
evolutionary is the main villain the
story is about rocket how he was
experimented on it's throughout the
whole movie and it's not that bad to
where I'm like covering my eyes or
anything like that but this is something
that people who truly know me personally
know that I hate that like half Android
half living things like that's like my
worst nightmare like I'll wake up one
day and like my chest has been replaced
by like robotic Parts I hate it makes me
feel uncomfortable and the good majority
of the movie was that so the whole
entire movie I'm sitting there going I
hate this I love it but I hate it but I
love this and then after I'm like hey
guys what what did you all think of this
and everyone's like loved it loved it
loved it cried Everyone crying blah blah
loved it my favorite Guardians movie and
if I take that part out and just be you
know neutral about it then yes it's
amazing and there truly were some just
unbelievable scenes the final fight
scene
just is fantastic and just the emotions
that it puts you through
it's so good and
I mean you feel for these characters
through everything they're going through
through the Happy Times the the bad
times
um
you just really feel for them now Adam
Warlock now
no spoilers
some people have been saying though that
they just didn't like how he was I get
it
I get the story they went with no it's
not anything like the comics
it's not so just get that out of your
mind and just accept that this is a a
new character Arc a new origin for Adam
Warlock and it's fine
uh Will Poulter did an excellent job
people were were worried about him you
know booking up and stuff no Will
Poulter did a great job the whole cast
the whole cast like everyone was
fantastic uh like like truly everyone
you know Sean Gunn's character crackling
amazing Cosmo
amazing loved Cosmo I mean everyone was
fantastic the movie was fantastic it's
just that one part I I don't like that
stuff I don't like the half living half
cyborg stuff it's it just bugs me that's
what this movie was about but it wasn't
even that bad I'm a I'm a I'm a wimp
when it comes to this stuff I'll just be
honest like the scary stuff like the
body horror stuff like it just it rubs
me the wrong way I try to avoid it but
even I can say that even with that stuff
I mean even that stuff like some of
these subjects made me cry from sadness
and happiness even though I'm so like I
have this aversion to it and yeah
it's amazing the post-credit scenes
um
lower your expectations
sorry kind of I said it
um
the first ones cool
and the second one's like whatever just
to be perfectly honest
um I I and I
I think that I think the first one's
really cool and set some stuff up for
the future and and truthfully the second
post credit scene does set stuff up for
the future as well in a way that you
it's it it's very obvious you'll see and
everyone clapped I clapped so there was
like that the really good part for the
second one they basically confirmed
something that everybody's just
wondering and when they do it you're
like okay sweet cool awesome uh
so yeah and that was it I really enjoyed
the movie
um I did love it even though I hate that
one side of it and I don't think this is
that's gonna you know really be the same
for a lot of people I think I'm in the
minority here and the majority are gonna
just love this movie
a lot I just that's what I think is
gonna happen so I mean
go watch it you'll love it you'll watch
it again after that and uh when you go
watch it when I do my spoiler talk let's
talk about it I look forward to hearing
from everybody and as usual I just want
to thank you all because I would not be
here would not have this opportunity
without any of you supporting me um it's
it's still to this day very surreal that
this is what I get to do for work
um
this is what I love I'm very fortunate
I'm very blessed and I will always try
to continue to be better for all you
because it's because of you
it's because of you all that I can do
this so I want to I want to work hard
for you all so look out for a spoiler
review coming soon of course after the
movie comes out as well and uh we'll be
doing some breakdowns about some stuff
that happened so
until then you all know what to do
please like the video it really helps
the channel and uh
I'm just sorry I'm just so grateful so
grateful for everything
um
yeah
I'm just gonna end it on that saying
that I love you guys I love you three
thousand love you in every universe and
now
catch you on the next video